[Music]
I'm Alvin kai-lan chef/owner of eggslut
a boy unit 120 and our new pop up here
in New York City called chefs club
counter our breakfast sandwich is kind
of like your master's degree in
breakfast sandwiches it's just all one
crazy gooey sandwich and I think when
you eat an egg sandwich and you take a
bite out of it you want it to be
something memorable that you have for
the rest of the day the way we cook the
Fairfax is always with a cold pan crack
cold eggs into the cold pan throw a nub
of butter and steer it before you even
put it on the heat and once you see that
the yolks and the whites have created
somewhat of a uniform color that's what
you want to throw it onto the heat we
use a spatula so that it doesn't like
agitate the proteins and the egg so it
comes out naturally velvety when you're
mixing it you're scraping the bottom of
the pan so that you're folding the eggs
over so you're creating almost like
layers of egg when you're cooking it in
the pan it starts to peel off the pan
and when it starts to like not get loose
and it just starts to like stay together
the eggs are basically telling you we're
done
[Music]
chives and eggs like are so amazing
together it's like having cheese or
peanut butter and jelly I literally use
it instead of pepper when it's not
plenty more taking out of the pan
because the pans hot so to keep cooking
it and it's gonna ruin that last 25
minutes that you tried making amazing
eggs you could have the most expensive
ingredients in between two pieces of
bread but if the bread is not perfectly
warm or cooked it ruins the whole thing
we pair it with sriracha mayo and then
you know we had that really nice melted
cheese and we do a caramelized onion let
me cook it for eight hours
low and slow so it brings up the natural
sweetness at the end of the day once
it's like all put together and you're
like whoa this is this is actually
really really good and I think that
that's really why it's become our number
one selling sandwich because I took the
time to learn how to be a decent line
cook and how to be a decent cook in
general I've been able to like focus
more on becoming a chef because I've
slowed it down
I guess when they say you put love into
it it's because you took the time dad
patience and you made something amazing
[Music]